My talk today is going to be
about project immortality.
It's about using GitHub to
make your work live forever.
You can follow me on Twitter
at underscore TanHo. Slides
are-- this is actually
a GitHub repository,
but the slides are
uploaded to that.
So I'd like to start by.
Wait a second.
Clicker yes, we like clickers.
So I'd like to introduce you
to the life and times of a data
science project.
This might sound
familiar to most of you.
Certainly the story of
most of my projects,
if not all of them.
You start by
importing some data,
whether that's
from scraping APIs,
a database, pre-existing data,
stuff that your company has,
whatever it is.
You start by
importing some data.
Then you get to know this data.
You do some wrangling.
You do some feature engineering.
You start doing some
exploratory data analysis.
Try to understand
how messy the data is
and how bad your data is.
Shout out to Jim.
And then, once you've kind
of done that,
kind of understand
that data little bit,
as from a human
perspective, you start
to try to teach your computer
to do something with it.
So you throw it
into a model, you
try to get some clustering
done or regressions
or try to predict
a number, and then
you study the results of
that output, you plot it,
and then you tweet the plot.
So, you know, you share
it with the world.
You've learned something new.
Here's what here's
what I've learned.
Here's, you know,
get some feedback on it.
Validation, 15 minutes of fame,
hopefully. Hopefully
everyone likes it.
You get feedback, and then
most projects die here, right?
And it's rightfully so because
you've learned something new.
You've you've done
what you set out to do.
You've learned something
from that project,
and you're ready to move on.
Sometime later,
this happens.
Relevant XKCD as ever.
Never have I ever felt
so close to another soul
and yet so helplessly alone
as when I Google this problem
and there's one result
a thread by someone
who studied the exact same
problem that I'm interested in,
and it was last
posted to in 2020.
2020 feels like 22,003, right?
Who were you,
DenverCoder9? Who were you?
What did you see?
What did you learn?
This story happens a lot, right?
And whether it's a Stack Overflow
answer or a problem, a GitHub,
sometimes now you'll Google and
you'll find a Twitter thread.
How do you help this person?
Actually, I'm not
that interested in how
you help that person because
the answer is they'll
reach out to you if
you're available.
You'll spend time and energy
and you'll give it back to them
if you have time.
Right? What I'm actually
more interested in
is how can your project
help this person?
Because that's not
always possible.
Whether you're constrained,
where your time has limits,
your energy has limits.
Your project should be able
to help them and get what
they need from it and move on.
So my, my
question, my talk today
is going be about
how can you help
your project help this person.
And I think that there's.
I skipped slide on me.
That GitHub has a bunch of
resources that can really
help you along this path.
So, who this talk is for?
This talk is for people who are
doing personal hobby projects.
It's for people who are
doing academic research.
interested in public and open
source work. More broadly,
it's for people who
don't have a budget when
they're doing their work.
And people who are interested
in helping others use their work
and helping their
projects live on.
So why do I care
so much about this?
This is me.
This is literally
my profile picture
on every single Twitter and
Twitch and everything else
about me.
In a past life, I was
a property manager,
grew up in the family business,
absolutely hated that job.
So, on the side I started
doing fantasy football.
Started analyzing it,
started teaching myself
some data analysis
to go with it.
Started with Excel
power query, eventually
learned R, taught myself
basically football analysis,
NFL fantasy football,
et cetera. Eventually
that led to a data
science career.
I got a job as in a home-building
company doing data science
and doing programming.
And eventually
and recently, I've
just accepted a position
with Zealous Analytics
to work on pro soccer.
So, you know, you can
turn, you can
make that career switch
if you're interested by doing
this sort of thing.
And then today along
the way, I've, I've
become a maintainer
of public NFL data
and I maintain nflverse and
ffverse R packages
for NFL and fantasy
football, respectively.
So why do I care
so much about this?
I've been the
hobbyist programmer.
I've been the person who's
broke and looking for wanting
to do stuff without a budget.
And I care today even
still about making sure
that people can build on
my work and can use my work
in their own projects.
So let's talk about one of
my projects, ffopportunity.
So it's a project that
uses NFL play-by-play data
to study expected
fantasy points.
Now, I'm not going to
go into the details
about NFL or expected fantasy points.
You don't need to know
anything about that.
But if you're interested,
expected fantasy points
help measure the value
of play opportunities
in fantasy football and you
can find my project here
GitHub dot com ffverse
ffopportunity. I'll take you
through the structure anyway, though.
So this might sound familiar.
You start by importing some
nflverse play-by-play data.
Then I wrangled some
features together.
Trained an XGBoost
model and then used it,
used that model, to
predict fantasy points.
Right? This is story of every
machine learning project.
Every data science project,
really.
Now what?
How could I make
ffopportunity live on?
I'm actually going to
frame this question
what is this person who
stumbles on my project
later interested in? And
what kind of questions
are they going to be asking?
How can they use and
improve on my model?
No model is perfect,
but they're useful.
And then understanding
how past work
has understanding the past
work in that field can
help you improve on that model.
Where the gaps are,
understand how to use it,
understand how to improve it.
Where to get that kind of thing.
Can new predictions be
automated every week?
Maybe they're good
with this model,
but they're interested in
how the prediction, what
the predictions are
and what the model says
about games that
haven't happened yet
and games that are
going to happen soon.
So can you automate new
predictions every week
of the NFL season?
There's a new slate of games
every week from September
through to January, February.
Lastly, where can they
find these predictions?
Where can I put it?
Where can they access
the predictions
in a way that's
not trying to ask
me to email them or tweet them
or send them these predictions?
It's no good if it
lives on my computer.
Right? So let's go through
these questions one by one.
Can someone use and
improve on my model?
There's a lot of
work in the R space now
in terms of reproducibility.
Renv is a great option.
Docker is a great option.
The one I actually like to
use is making it a package
and I'm not talking
about making it for CRAN,
but I think there's two
elements of packages
that I think are
really underrated
and help kind of build
things going forward.
One of them is adding
a description file
and the other one is
wrapping code into functions.
Adding a description file.
One of the things that
addind a description file does,
it forces you or asks
you to add a license.
And a license is really
important, especially
when you're doing
public work because it
tells people what you're OK
with them doing with your work.
Right? So if you want
them to if you're
OK with doing it, them
doing anything with that,
say so. Add an MIT license.
That's what that's
basically they're for.
If you want them to
only use this work
to help extend public
work, you can use a license
like GPL v three, right?
So just choosing
the license helps
communicate that you want
them to use that work.
And by sharing that work
to them with that license,
people can understand
what you're OK
with them doing with it.
The other thing that it does
is it makes dependencies.
It makes installation of
dependencies really easy
because you're forced to
list all of the dependencies.
And if you're able to also
list them in versions,
it makes things like remotes
or pakc or pacman work
because they can read the
description file from GitHub,
and then install all
the dependencies for you
while you're installing
this package.
For this package.
And even if it doesn't
have any functions in it,
it'll still install the
dependencies for you
and then you can use that in
running the script after you've
cloned it on GitHub.
Of course, usethis
has this covered,
so you don't actually need to
type out a description file.
It's got four functions
that you need to do
exactly what I'm talking about.
Use description, use
MIT license, use package
for each package
that you're using.
Then once you've added all
the package you use, use
latest dependencies and
it's going to version
lock the version
that's on your machine.
So it'll put on, put
that in as the version.
And then you've got, you, got
you set this up to for success.
The other thing that I like
to do, this is kind of the next level,
is to wrap logic into functions.
It's really easy for users.
So from your end of
things, what you need to do
is convert the hard-coded
variables and data frames
to arguments, extract functions.
A cool feature in RStudio,
control Control Alt X.
And then if you copy and
paste or if you select
the entire code chunk and
you press this shortcut,
I think it's Command Option X.
I don't use a Mac,
but it's related.
It'll automatically
create a function
and put the skeleton of
your code in a function
and take all the variables
and put them into arguments.
So this already basically
does it for you.
And then the other thing you
can do is add some usage notes.
I don't say documentation here because
documentation scares people,
but really understanding
how you use
logic, how you use the function
and what the function is meant
to do will help
other people kind of
understand where
you're going with it.
And the goal is to make it
easy for users to run, right?
So R users love functions.
They understand
exactly what to do
when you give them a function,
you put arguments into it
and then you kind
of go from there.
OK. So we talked about packages.
That's all that's
the bare minimum.
There's a whole bunch
more in packages.
There's a whole book on it.
But from my end of things,
that's the bare minimum.
The next thing I'm
going to talk about
is how can you predict
new automation?
Can you automate
predictions every week?
Right? Because the users who
don't care about the model
itself are really only
interested in the output
of the model.
So can you automate giving
them a model every single week?
The answer is yes, of course.
With GitHub Actions.
This is literally
the 20-line file that automates
scripts, the automates that
automates the ffopportunity
predictions,
and it uses the description
file that we just
talked about to run every
night after every game.
So that's four or
5:00 AM on Monday,
Tuesday and Friday from
September to January.
And then it installs
R on the machine.
The virtual machine installs
the R packages from the dependencies
that I listed in my description,
and then it runs a script.
And that's it.
That's all you need to do.
So you're obviously there's
a whole bunch of magic that
happens in the backend here.
But from an end
user perspective,
as someone automating
your projects,
this is already this is you're
leaning on a bunch of work
by the r-lib actions
team that is out there
and it's ready for you to use.
Right? And GitHub
actions is free.
If you've got public
work, public projects,
there's no action limits,
action minutes limits.
That sounded weird anyways.
The last question and the one
I think that more people need
to know about is, where can
I make predictions accessible?
So if you're already we're
already talking about GitHub.
So the common
approach is to just
commit things to your
GitHub repository, right?
Well, there's three things,
there's three common
problems with that.
I'll list I'll talk
about them here.
File size limits,
inefficient binary data
storage, and commit
history chaos.
We'll start with
file size limits.
This is approximate, but
I think the GitHub file
size limits are something
like 75 megabytes per file
and 2 gigabytes per repo.
In today's modern age, that's
basically nothing, right?
So it's very easy
to go through this.
So if you have a
CSV, for example,
you might think,
OK, well, maybe what
I should do is use an RDS file
or a parquet file to use arrow,
or whatever kind
of small file size.
I think my friend Seb
he likes to use QS.
Cuz same idea.
They're all binary files.
So the problem with that
is that version control
is incredibly bad at
dealing with binary files.
Here's an example
of a repository that
has a daily automation
that basically overwrites
an RDS file every single day.
It's really tiny.
So I've annotated for you.
The actual data
in this repository
is 60 megabytes in size.
And then Git, since
I think this is
over the course of
six months or a year,
has automatically backed up
six gigabytes worth of data
that I didn't know
about until I decided
that I need to clone it down
and do something with the code.
So and then once
I closed it down,
you can't push it back
to GitHub because Git
has a limit of two gigabytes.
So I actually like rage
tweeted a whole bunch of this stuff
when I found this out.
So if you really if
you're really keen,
you can go find it.
So it's incredibly bad.
And what's happening is that
Git version control is literally
tracking versions,
right? And what it does is
it compares the differences
and tries to log
the differences.
But binary files have or
are entirely different
every time you write it.
So it naturally stores a copy.
Right? And that's why Git
is really bad at dealing
with binary files.
So even if you're into parquet and
the latest and greatest there,
it's very quick, especially
when you pair it with actions,
that you kill your
repo like this.
Lastly, this is another problem.
If you're committing to the same
people that your code lives in,
you end up with 6,000 commits.
Now pop quiz which
commit did I, did I,
did I make a typo
in and automatically
write to the wrong file?
Well, it was like
4,222 commits ago.
How do I revert to that?
Right? It's impossible.
So commit history chaos.
There's obviously
better solutions.
Here are some meh solutions.
There is Git Large
File Storage, takes
care of some of the
large file size problems,
but it also wrecks
your Git repository.
It's impossible to
collaborate with.
It's really hard
for users to work
with because your data isn't
actually stored on GitHub
in files anymore.
Sharded everywhere.
Amazon S3 buckets, two problems.
One, they cost money.
Again, we're talking about
free, especially in sustainable
projects.
And the other problem
is that it's stored away
from your repository.
So you have no idea what data is
available for that repository.
And so someone's got this bucket
and it's got things on it.
It's really hard to work with
visually for the novice user,
someone who's not
using accessing
a terminal in a
programming perspective
to understand what
data is there.
Lastly, people still use Dropbox
for this sort of problem,
but that's also really
difficult to work with.
But now from the command line,
say, how do you get files
back and forth from there?
The real solution again, pairing
with the GitHub theme GitHub
Releases.
And GitHub Releases is it's
kind of a lesser known thing,
but you can make a new release
and releases are stored right
next to your repo.
So if you go through this
section beside your repo,
there's releases. You
make a new release,
you upload files to the release,
and then when you're ready,
you can update those
files as desired.
How is this different
from the other GitHub
data repos?
Well, there's friendly
file size limits.
So each file that you
upload to a release
is understood to be bigger.
So the actual limit for a
file is like two gigabytes,
and you can upload as many
of these files as you want.
So that's much more generous
than two gigabytes in total
and 75 megabytes. You
version by choice.
So when you upload,
you overwrite the file
unless you make a
new release, right?
And if you're ready
to archive that data,
you make any release, upload
to that new repository
and you still have
the old version.
It keeps your commit history clean.
You're manually uploading or uploading
through the API. Data
stays with your project.
So if I'm interested
in what data
is available within
the nflverse data package,
you go through the releases, you
figure it out. You can point
and click and download.
And best of all, it's free
both for public and private
repositories.
Of course, R is
wonderful, and there's
a package for everything.
The piggyback package, which
I started working with,
and it's originally
by Carl, I'm gonna
this, Boettiger came up with
three functions that basically
run that whole process.
First is PB release create.
You create a new release.
PB upload to upload a file
to a specific release.
PB download lets you
download all the files,
some of the files, or just
one file from that release.
So to recap, today I
presented three tools
for project immortality.
Talked about R package
infrastructure to help
make things easy
to install and also
to communicate what you want
people to do with your work.
Talked about GitHub Actions, to
schedule and automate things.
And then GitHub Releases as
an awesome and wonderful way
to store data.
So with that, with those
three tools under your belt,
I'd like to leave you
with one last question.
How can you help your
projects help others,
now and into the future?
Thank you.